OK, real estate shoppers-- some important factors to take into account when you're choosing a neighborhood-- price, how long your commute will be, schools, safety, does Mos Def live nearby? That last one was a factor for Adam when he was looking at this one neighborhood in New York.
好了，各位房地产买家，在选择街区时需要考虑一些重要因素——价格、通勤时间、学校、安全性，还有Mos Def是否住在附近？最后一个因素是Adam在纽约寻找街区时考虑的问题。
The fact that Mos Def allegedly lived there. I think at the time, he and Erykah Badu might have been together. I did run into Mos Def at the overpriced bodega on the corner and did the creepy thing of, like, seeing him through the window, waiting for him outside, and accosting him the second he came outside and being like, "yo, man. Your album was really significant to me." And he looked terrified. You know, he couldn't wait to get out of there with, like, his $12 mangoes or whatever.
据说Mos Def住在那里。我想当时他和Erykah Badu可能在一起。我在拐角处那家价格虚高的杂货店撞见了Mos Def，还做了件令人毛骨悚然的事，比如透过窗户盯着他，在外面等他，等他一出来就上前搭讪，说：“嘿，哥们。你的专辑对我意义重大。”他看起来吓坏了。你知道，他拿着那12美元的芒果之类的东西，急着想离开那里。
This was a Brooklyn neighborhood called Fort Greene. It was the year 2000, and the neighborhood was in the early stages of gentrifying. Adam left his cell number with a bunch of real estate brokers.
这是布鲁克林一个叫Fort Greene的街区。那是2000年，这个街区正处于绅士化改造的初期。Adam把他的手机号码留给了很多房地产经纪人。
And Fort Greene was very real estate broker intensive. You know, it's not a big neighborhood. There were possibly more brokers than there were blocks. So I left my phone number with a bunch of these brokers. And I was walking up Fulton Street probably an hour after dropping all these phone numbers off when I got a call from one of these brokers.
Fort Greene那里房地产经纪人特别多。你知道，那不是个大街区。那里的经纪人可能比街区还要多。所以我把手机号码留给了他们中的很多人。我在留下这些号码大约一小时后走在富尔顿街上，就接到了其中一位经纪人的电话。
And she was a British lady. And she started describing to me an apartment. And it had high ceilings and wood floors and lots of natural light. And it sounded great. But the only problem was the apartment was not in Forte Greene. It was in Bed-Stuy, Bedford-Stuyvesant.
她是一位英国女士。她开始向我描述一套公寓。那套公寓有很高的天花板，木地板，采光极好。听起来很不错。但唯一的问题是这套公寓不在Fort Greene，而是在Bed-Stuy，即贝德福德-斯图维森。
Bed-Stuy-- further from Manhattan, more crime, less gentrified. For instance, Adam says if you visited both neighborhoods, Fort Greene and Bed-Stuy, and compared what the fake businesses were like that marijuana dealers worked out of--
Bed-Stuy——离曼哈顿更远，犯罪率更高，绅士化程度更低。例如，Adam说如果你参观过Fort Greene和Bed-Stuy这两个街区，对比一下那些大麻贩子经营的虚假店铺是什么样的——
Like how plausible are they as businesses? You know? So if it's the kind of thing where you walk into a bodega and there's, like, one can of grape soda and a box of baking powder and a shady looking dude behind six inches of reinforced bulletproof glass, then your neighborhood is far from gentrified. Whereas Fort Greene at that point had businesses which I went to because I wanted to actually partake of their legal goods and services and didn't even know that they were weed spots. Like there was this hat shop that I actually bought a hat at. And everybody looked at me like, you knot that's not really a hat shop, right? So that was the level that Fort Greene was at.
比如它们作为店面看起来有多可信？你知道吗？如果那是那种你走进杂货店，里面只有一罐葡萄汽水、一盒发酵粉，还有一个看起来很可疑的家伙坐在六英寸厚的防弹玻璃后面，那你的街区距离绅士化还很远。而当时的Fort Greene，里面的店铺是我会为了购买合法的商品和服务而光顾的，我甚至不知道它们是大麻窝点。比如有一家帽子店，我真的在那里买过帽子。每个人都看着我，好像在说：“你知道那不是真的帽子店，对吧？”Fort Greene当时就是那种程度。
OK. So transitional.
好的，所以是处于转型期。
Yes, transitional.
是的，转型期。
But less transitional than Bed-Stuy. So he bought records in Bed-Stuy, he ate dinner in Bed-Stuy, and, as he told the real estate broker, did not want to live in Bed-Stuy.
但比Bed-Stuy的转型程度要低。所以他在Bed-Stuy买唱片，在Bed-Stuy吃晚饭，正如他告诉房地产经纪人的那样，他不想住在Bed-Stuy。
And so I said, "you know, the apartment sounds cool. But I'm going to pass. Bed-Stuy's a little bit Boondocksickle for me. So call me if you get a Fort Greene listing." And very quickly and professionally, she switched gears and started trying to convince me that I should check out the Bed-Stuy apartment.
所以我说：“你知道，公寓听起来不错。但我还是算了吧。Bed-Stuy对我来说有点太乡下了。所以如果有Fort Greene的房源再打给我。”她很快且很专业地转换了态度，开始试图说服我一定要去看看Bed-Stuy的那套公寓。
So she said, look, "I don't know what you've heard about Bed-Stuy. But it's really very nice. It's very safe. It's changing very fast. A lot of white people are moving there." And I stopped dead in my tracks, offended and surprised that after about 10 seconds on the phone with me, this woman wanted to have this kind of conspiratorial nudge-nudge-wink-wink conversation as a way of letting me know that Bed-Stuy was safe for people like me. I was mostly offended by it.
她说：“听着，我不知道你听说过什么关于Bed-Stuy的事。但它真的非常好。非常安全。它变化非常快。很多白人都搬到那里去了。”我停下了脚步，感到既被冒犯又很惊讶，因为在电话里聊了不到10秒，这个女人就想跟我进行这种心照不宣的暗示性对话，以此让我知道Bed-Stuy对像我这样的人来说是安全的。我对此感到非常反感。
So I figured that I should end that line of conversation as forcefully as possible and kind of shock her back. So I said, I don't like white people that much, and I'm not trying to live around too many of them. And there was, like, silence on the phone. And then she said something along the lines of, "you-- you don't like white people?"
所以我认为我应该尽快以最强硬的方式结束这种对话，并反击吓吓她。所以我说，我不怎么喜欢白人，而且我不想住在一个周围有很多白人的地方。电话那头沉默了。然后她说了类似这样的话：“你……你不喜欢白人？”
And I was like, "no. You know, I don't hate them or anything. But they walk around like they own the planet. They're really entitled. They don't make particularly good neighbors. So no, I'm not really trying to live around too many of them."
我说：“不。你知道，我并不是讨厌他们什么的。但他们走起路来好像拥有整个地球一样。他们真的很自以为是。他们不是特别好的邻居。所以不，我真的不想住在周围有太多白人的地方。”
And there was more silence on the phone. And then very slowly and deliberately she said, "sir, I'm very sorry. I didn't mean to offend you. I can tell from your voice that you're obviously African American."
电话那头又是一阵沉默。然后她非常缓慢且慎重地说：“先生，我非常抱歉。我无意冒犯你。我从你的声音能听出来，你显然是非裔美国人。”
And I cut her off. And I was like, "no, no, no. You got it wrong. I'm white."
我打断了她，说：“不，不，不。你搞错了。我是白人。”
And then I add something like, "no offense. She says, oh, I'm not offended. I get it. I'm black," which, because of her British accent, hadn't occurred to me.
然后我加了一句类似的话：“别介意。她说，哦，我没被冒犯。我明白了。我是黑人。”因为她的英国口音，我之前根本没往这方面想。
And the next thing I remember about the conversation is basically that the two of us both start laughing because in the space of about a minute we had both made so many assumptions and cycled through so many identities. The absurdity of it just, I think, hit us both at once.
关于那次谈话，我记得的下一件事基本上就是我们俩都开始笑了，因为在不到一分钟的时间里，我们都作出了太多的假设，经历了太多的身份转变。我觉得那种荒谬感一下子击中了我们俩。
I assumed that he was black.
我以为他是黑人。
Well, does he sound black to you in this recording?
嗯，在这段录音里，他听起来像黑人吗？
Yes, he does. And it's just-- I realize it's the way he spreads his words out for me.
是的，确实像。而且我意识到，这是因为他那种说话的语调。
After talking to Adam, I got in touch with the real estate broker, Noreen Sumpter. And she remembers this incident the same way he does with one exception. She says she would not have said, "I'm sorry. I did not mean to offend you. Are you African American?"
在和Adam交谈后，我联系了那位房地产经纪人Noreen Sumpter。她对这件事的记忆和他的一样，只有一个例外。她说她绝不会说“我很抱歉，我无意冒犯你，你是由于非裔美国人吗？”
No, I didn't say that. I just directly-- "oh, so you black." Do I sound like I'd be, (AMERICAN ACCENT) "sir, are you sorry? I'm sorry." (DROPS ACCENT) No, I'm not that. I'm like, "oh, really? You don't like white people? Are you black?"
不，我没那么说。我只是直接说——“哦，原来你是黑人。”我听起来像是会说（美国口音）“先生，你很抱歉吗？我很抱歉。”（恢复原声）不，我不是那种人。我是说，“哦，真的吗？你不喜欢白人？你是黑人吗？”
She's no longer in real estate these days. She's a life coach. But she says the thing that set Adam off-- the race-baiting, wink, wink, don't-worry-a-lot-of-white-people-are-moving-there-- was not something she said to white clients or to anybody else. She only said it to him because--
她现在已经不做房地产了。她是位人生教练。但她说，真正让Adam生气的那件事——那种种族诱导、心照不宣的暗示“别担心，很多白人正搬到那里去”——并不是她会对白人客户或其他人说的话。她之所以对他那么说，是因为——
I assumed that he was black and he was scared to move into a black neighborhood with black people is why I said it to him. Right? Like, what is this guy? You're a black guy. What are you-- so that's why I said, there's a lot of white people moving there, meaning that you're black. If you're a black man, you should be comfortable in that neighborhood.
我假设他是黑人，而他害怕搬进一个住着黑人的黑人街区，所以我才对他那么说。对吧？就像是，这家伙是怎么回事？你是个黑人，你这是在……所以我才说，有很多白人搬到那里，意思是你是黑人。如果你是一个黑人男性，你应该在那个街区感到舒服才对。
Like white people aren't scared to live there. Why can't you?
就好像白人都不怕住在那儿。你为什么不能？
Yeah. Like what's going on? What's over there with you why you wouldn't move there? But he wasn't a black man. He was a white guy.
对。就像是，发生了什么事？你那边有什么问题导致你不想搬到那儿？但他不是黑人，他是个白人。
I love the efficiency of this story. Like, I like how we all have people in our lives who it takes years to figure, like, oh, I totally misjudged this person. And this is the most efficient version of getting somebody wrong and realizing you've gotten it wrong. Like, you couldn't do it in fewer sentences.
我喜欢这个故事的高效。我喜欢我们生活中总有那些需要花几年时间才能搞清楚的人，比如，噢，我完全错判了这个人。这是误解某人并意识到自己错了的最快版本。你不可能用更少的句子完成这个过程。
Look, I'm the queen of the world. You know what? The people in my building call me Queen Nor, Goddess of the Universe. So that makes me realize that I can solve anything. Anything can be solved through a conversation. I did assume, and he assumed, and we both assumed back and forth. But we resolved it in, like, a heartbeat. So, hey, kudos for us.
看，我是世界女王。你知道吗？大楼里的人叫我诺女王，宇宙女神。所以这让我意识到我可以解决任何事情。任何事情都可以通过对话解决。我假设了，他也假设了，我们互相猜测。但我们在瞬间就解决了它。所以，嘿，为我们喝彩。
Sometimes people's answers to questions really surprise me. Well, today on our program, people who are in this same situation, where they realize, oh, no. I thought you were one thing, and I got it wrong. You are not that person. Except in these other cases, they do not have Queen Nor to help them wrap it up so quickly. And so some of these misunderstandings and misperceptions, they drag on for years, with a lot more feelings attached to them.
有时人们对问题的回答真的让我很惊讶。今天在我们的节目中，有处于同样境地的人，他们意识到，噢，不。我以为你是某样人，结果我搞错了。你不是那个人。只是在这些情况下，他们没有“诺女王”来帮助他们这么快地解决问题。所以其中一些误解和认知偏差，拖延了几年，还附带了更多的情绪。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, "Who's Really On Line Two?" And now, a radio host discovering things about his listeners that he wishes were not true, obviously one of the worst things that could ever happen to a person. I think we can all agree on that. I'm saying this as if this is a problem in my life. I don't-- it's not at all.
第一幕，“热线二是谁？”现在，一位电台主持人发现了关于听众的一些他希望不是真的事情，显然这是一个人可能遇到的最糟糕的事情之一。我想我们都可以同意这一点。我这么说就好像这是我生活中的一个问题。我并不是——根本不是。
Anyway, it recently happened to Tony Beam, host of the radio show Christian Worldview Today in South Carolina. Zoe Chace tells the story.
总之，这最近发生在南卡罗来纳州《今日基督教世界观》节目的主持人Tony Beam身上。Zoe Chace讲述了这个故事。
Tony's on early mornings, 92.9 FM, 660 AM, weekdays. His show is for and by the evangelical community. Politics, news, a little sports, God-- that's his show.
Tony在工作日的清晨播出，92.9 FM，660 AM。他的节目是为福音派社区准备的，也由他们参与。政治、新闻、一点体育、上帝——这就是他的节目。
"All right, welcome back. Hour number two of Christian Worldview Today is coming off the shelf, and it's coming straight at you. But just receive it. It's a good thing."
“好了，欢迎回来。《今日基督教世界观》的第二小时节目马上开始，直接传送到你那里。只要接收就行了。这是件好事。”
Tony and his callers speak the same language. They hate Obamacare, deficit spending. They feel the Christian right gets no respect from the Republican establishment. And when Tony endorses a presidential candidate, enough of his listeners agree with him that candidates seek him out. They come on the air with him. He went with Huckabee in '08, Santorum in 2012.
Tony和他的听众说着同样的语言。他们讨厌奥巴马医改，讨厌赤字支出。他们觉得福音派基督教在共和党体制内不受尊重。当Tony支持某位总统候选人时，他的听众中有足够多的人同意他的看法，以至于候选人都会来找他。他们会来到他的节目中。他在08年支持了Huckabee，2012年支持了Santorum。
Last spring, Ted Cruz invited Tony and his wife up to DC. He sat them down in a private Washington apartment and made a pitch. He was going to unite the Tea Party, the libertarians, the evangelicals, and win. Tony told me how much he liked him.
去年春天，Ted Cruz邀请Tony和他的妻子去华盛顿。他在华盛顿的一间私人公寓里接待了他们，并进行了游说。他打算团结茶党、自由意志主义者和福音派，从而赢得大选。Tony告诉我他有多喜欢他。
Not only did he have the principles and convictions that I have, but he had a political strategy that I thought would succeed. And when we walked out of that meeting, my wife, who is not near as involved in politics or fascinated by as I am, she looked at me and she says, you do what you want. I'm voting for that guy.
他不仅拥有我所拥有的原则和信念，而且他还有一种我认为会成功的政治策略。当我们走出那次会议时，我妻子，她不像我那样热衷于政治，她看着我，她说，你想怎么做就怎么做。我要投那个家伙的票。
Not long after, he went on the radio and endorsed Cruz, a lifelong evangelical conservative.
不久之后，他在电台上支持了Cruz，一位终身的福音派保守派。
"I believe he's the right man for the job. I believe he's the right person that's got insider knowledge. But he's an outsider within his own party because he's willing to call out his party. That impresses me."
“我相信他是胜任这项工作的合适人选。我相信他是个拥有内部知识的合适人选。但他也是他自己党内的局外人，因为他愿意公开批评他的党派。这让我印象深刻。”
Tony knows this scene-- anti-establishment Christian Republicans in South Carolina. Year after year, he goes to the state political gatherings, the Silver Elephant dinner, Jeff Duncan's Faith in Freedom BBQ. He grew up listening to Ronald Reagan on the radio, sitting in the kitchen with his dad.
Tony很了解这一场景——南卡罗来纳州的反建制基督教共和党人。年复一年，他参加州政治集会、银象晚宴、Jeff Duncan的“信仰与自由”烧烤会。他从小听着收音机里的里根演讲长大，和父亲一起坐在厨房里。
And he was telling me, you know, this guy has got the answer for the future.
他在告诉我，你知道，这家伙对未来有答案。
That is a real American Republican origin story.
这是一个真正的美国共和党起源故事。
It is. It really is.
是的，确实是。
You and your dad in the kitchen, the eggs frying, listening to Ronald Reagan on the radio.
你和你父亲在厨房里，煎着鸡蛋，听着收音机里的罗纳德·里根。
I can hear it. And I can actually, I can smell the-- I mean, most people it was bacon and eggs. My dad loved livermush, believe it or not. And he would fry livermush and make like livermush and egg sandwiches.
我能听到那个声音。我实际上——我能闻到那个味道——我是说，大多数人是培根和鸡蛋。我父亲喜欢肝泥饼，信不信由你。他会煎肝泥饼，做那种肝泥饼和鸡蛋三明治。
Tony was especially excited this election year. As the establishment candidates, Bush and Scott Walker, flamed out, his guy Ted Cruz was on the rise. It looked like he had a real shot at being the nominee. Obviously, there is also this other candidate in the race-- Donald Trump. But Tony wasn't worried about Trump. He figured Trump does not fit in with people built on livermush and the Bible.
Tony在选举年特别兴奋。随着布什和斯科特·沃克等建制派候选人的出局，他支持的Ted Cruz声势上涨。看起来他很有机会成为提名人。显然，竞选中还有另一位候选人——唐纳德·特朗普。但Tony并不担心特朗普。他认为特朗普不适合那些靠肝泥饼和圣经生活的人。
When Donald Trump got in the race, I said, pssh. In three weeks, we'll be done here because there's no way that people are going to go chasing after him.
当唐纳德·特朗普进入竞选时，我说，呸。三周后我们就结束了，因为人们绝不可能去追随他。
Then came the first Republican debate, the one where Megyn Kelly, the Fox News anchor, asked Trump about some stuff he'd said about women. And unlike this week, Trump was there to answer those questions.
然后是第一次共和党辩论，福克斯新闻主播Megyn Kelly问了特朗普一些关于女性的问题。和本周不同，特朗普当时在那里回答了这些问题。
"You've called women you don't like fat pigs, dogs, slobs, and disgusting animals. Your Twitter account--"
“你管你不喜欢的女人叫胖猪、狗、懒婆娘和令人作呕的动物。你的推特账号——”
"Only Rosie O'Donnell."
“只是罗西·奥唐奈。”
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
（欢呼和掌声）
"No, it wasn't."
“不，不仅仅是她。”
I'll point out over this 16 seconds of cheering and applause that this turned out to be a very controversial line of questioning.
我要指出的是，这16秒的欢呼和掌声背后，这成了一个非常有争议的质询环节。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
（欢呼和掌声）
OK, still going.
好了，还在继续。
"Thank you."
“谢谢。”
"For the record, it was well beyond Rosie O'Donnell."
“记录在案，这远不止罗西·奥唐奈一人。”
"Yes, I'm sure it was."
“是的，我确定是的。”
"Your Twitter account has several disparaging comments about women's looks. You once told a contestant on Celebrity Apprentice it would be a pretty picture to see her on her knees. Does that sound to you like the temperament of a man we should elect as president?"
“你的推特账号上有几条关于女性外貌的贬损评论。你曾经告诉《名人学徒》的一位参赛者，看到她跪在地上会是一幅漂亮的画面。这听起来像是一个我们应该选举为总统的人所应有的气质吗？”
I thought it was fair game. I mean, this is-- Democrats do pound Republicans with a war on women. And now we've got a guy who's kind of the front-runner who's attacking the way a woman looks and attacking other women by name? Are you kidding me?
我认为这是公平的游戏。我的意思是，这是——民主党人确实用“对女性的战争”来猛烈抨击共和党人。现在我们有一个领跑者，他在攻击女人的外貌，还在点名攻击其他女性？你在开玩笑吗？
"And frankly, what I say-- and oftentimes, it's fun. It's kidding. We have a good time. What I say is what I say."
“坦率地说，我说的是——而且通常，这是好玩。是开玩笑。我们玩得很开心。我说什么就是什么。”
I come and crack the microphone after that first debate. And I'm like, [GIGGLING] Trump's done. This is it. He's really stepped in it now. And I'm plastered with people calling me telling me how glad they are the way Trump handled himself and that he won that debate. And I was stunned. I thought I was doing somebody else's talk show, that they had switched frequencies on me and not told me, and that I was actually doing a show from a different location. This is crazy. This is not who we are.
那场辩论后，我打开麦克风，说（咯咯笑），特朗普完了。就是这样。他这次真的惹祸了。结果全是人们打进电话，告诉我他们有多高兴特朗普应对得当，而且他赢得了那场辩论。我惊呆了。我以为我在做别人的脱口秀，他们切换了我的频道却没告诉我，而我实际上是在从另一个地方做节目。这太疯狂了。这不是我们这样的人。
And that was just the beginning.
那仅仅是个开始。
"And I've been waiting for years to hear a politician that talks the way Donald Trump talks. Now is he going to deliver? I don't know. But I'm telling you, I'm a Trumpeter. I mean, unless he's a liar, he's saying all the right things."
“而且我多年来一直等着听一位政治家说唐纳德·特朗普说的话。他能兑现吗？我不知道。但我告诉你，我是个特朗普主义者。我是说，除非他是骗子，否则他说了所有正确的话。”
"Yeah."
“是的。”
"And whether his conservative credentials are bona fide or not, that's not the point. See, anybody can change. Ronald Reagan did, as we all know."
“不管他的保守派资历是否属实，那不是重点。看，任何人都可以改变。正如我们所知，里根就改变过。”
"Alex, Alex. I hate to interrupt a great rant, and that was a great rant. And as far as rants goes, that was right up there. But you said it doesn't-- I don't know if his conservative credentials are true or not. But it doesn't matter. It doesn't?"
“Alex，Alex。我不想打断一段精彩的咆哮，那确实很精彩。而且就咆哮而言，那是顶级的。但你说这没关系——我不知道他的保守派资历是否真实。但这不重要吗？真的不重要吗？”
Calls like these got under Tony's skin real quick.
这样的电话很快让Tony感到恼火。
"Donald Trump made a statement a couple of weeks ago that he wants to pursue the families of the--"
“唐纳德·特朗普几周前发表声明说，他想追杀那些……”
"Yes, yes."
“是的，是的。”
"--of these jihadists."
“……那些圣战分子的家属。”
"Yeah, wants to kill them."
“是的，想杀了他们。”
"And it was sixth-grade outrage. And I can give you examples of two presidents who actually did that. One was the third president of the United States. And the other was the 39th president of the United States."
“这简直是六年级的暴行。我可以给你举两个总统这样做的例子。一个是美国第三任总统，另一个是美国第39任总统。”
"OK. So you think that's a good idea?"
“好的。所以你认为这是个好主意？”
"And by the  way, so did Harry Truman when he dropped the atom bombs."
“顺便说一句，哈里·杜鲁门投下原子弹时也是这么想的。”
"You think it's a good idea? You think it's a good idea. I'm not asking you-- no."
“你认为这是个好主意？你认为这是个好主意。我不是问你——不。”
"I didn't say it was a good idea, Tony."
“Tony，我没说这是个好主意。”
"Put a stake in the ground, Gene."
“表个态吧，Gene。”
"But this is warfare. This is what happens."
“但这是战争。这就是会发生的事。”
"If you're gonna call and do this, put a stake in the ground. I'm asking you. I'm calling you out. I'm calling you out. Do you want to ban all Muslims from the United States, and do you want to kill all the family members of anybody who's ever been involved in terrorism? Is that what you want? Is that what you want?"
“如果你要打电话来说这个，就表个态。我在问你。我在质问你。我在质问你。你想禁止所有穆斯林进入美国吗，而且你想杀掉所有曾经参与恐怖活动的人的家属吗？这就是你想要的吗？这就是你想要的吗？”
"I want--"
“我想要——”
"No, no no!"
“不，不，不！”
Tony's a pastor, a doctor of ministry from Southern Baptist Theological Seminary. And his big problem with Trump is that he's not a good Christian. He doesn't share the values that govern Tony's entire life.
Tony是一位牧师，拥有美南浸信会神学院的神学博士学位。他对特朗普最大的问题在于他不是一个好的基督徒。他不认同那些支撑Tony整个人生的价值观。
For instance, last summer, an interviewer asked Trump if he'd ever asked God for forgiveness of his sins. And Trump was like, "why should I? I don't make mistakes. I mean, I drink the wine. I eat the cracker." Some people thought it was funny. Tony did not.
例如，去年夏天，一位采访者问特朗普是否曾请求上帝宽恕他的罪过。特朗普说，“我为什么要请求宽恕？我不犯错。我是说，我喝葡萄酒，我吃饼干。”有些人觉得这很有趣。Tony不觉得。
Given that, nothing drives him crazier than when his listeners try to defend Trump along biblical lines, like when that guy Gene calls in to talk about Trump and the Second Book of Kings.
鉴于此，没有什么比他的听众试图从圣经的角度为特朗普辩护更让他抓狂的了，比如那个叫Gene的家伙打来电话谈论特朗普和《列王纪下》。
"When I sit here and listen to Trump, I agree with a lot of what he's saying. And I want to remind your audience of a person in the Bible."
“当我坐在这里听特朗普说话时，我同意他所说的大部分内容。我想提醒你的听众圣经中的一个人。”
"Oh, my gosh."
“哦，天哪。”
"Who took down Jezebel? What was the name--"
“是谁干掉了耶洗别？那个名字是……”
OK, what Gene is talking about is in the Second Book of Kings, this guy Jehu murdered Queen Jezebel because she had pagan idols around the kingdom. Then he threw her body to the dogs. Jehu was like a warrior against a corrupt culture.
好了，Gene谈论的是《列王纪下》，这个叫耶户的家伙谋杀了耶洗别女王，因为她在王国里设立异教偶像。然后他把她的尸体扔给狗吃。耶户就像是一个反抗腐败文化的战士。
"His name was Jehu. Do you remember that?"
“他的名字叫耶户。你还记得吗？”
"I remember. And you think--"
“我记得。而且你认为……”
"The Book of Kings."
“《列王纪》。”
"--Donald Trump is Jehu?"
“……唐纳德·特朗普就是耶户？”
"Yes. Yes."
“是的。是的。”
"You do?"
“你真的这么认为？”
"Yes. Remember, Jehu was not a righteous man in God's eyes. And God used Jehu to fulfill Elijah's prophecy regarding Jezebel."
“是的。记住，耶户在上帝眼中并不是一个正直的人。上帝利用耶户实现了以利亚关于耶洗别的预言。”
"But you believe that God-- yeah, whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa, Gene. We have such chaos in this country that we would look to a man like Donald Trump, who has no core value system, to lead us back to the place that we need to be as a country."
“但你相信上帝——是的，哇！哇！哇！哇！哇，Gene。我们国家现在这么混乱，以至于我们要仰仗像唐纳德·特朗普这样没有任何核心价值体系的人，来引领我们回到国家需要的正轨上。”
"I think Trump is gonna realize that he may well have to work with the Congress--"
“我认为特朗普会意识到他可能确实需要与国会合作……”
In a recent poll of South Carolina evangelical voters, Trump is leading, eight points ahead of Ted Cruz. Nationally, he's ahead by more than 15% with evangelical voters. Tony is in this very real struggle that I'd say a lot of anti-establishment Republicans are in. There is a part of the Donald Trump thing that appeals to him. Take this moment from the South Carolina Republican debate.
在最近的一项南卡罗来纳州福音派选民民意调查中，特朗普领先，比Ted Cruz高出八个百分点。在全国范围内，他在福音派选民中的支持率领先超过15%。Tony正处于一种非常真实的挣扎中，我相信很多反建制共和党人都处于这种挣扎中。唐纳德·特朗普的某些特质确实吸引了他。看看南卡罗来纳州共和党辩论中的这一刻。
"And I can say, oh, I'm not angry. I'm very angry because our country is being run horribly. And I will gladly accept the mantle of anger. Our military is a disaster. Our health care is a horror show. Obamacare, we're gonna repeal it--"
“我可以这么说，哦，我不生气。我非常生气，因为我们的国家被管理得一团糟。我将很乐意承担愤怒的重任。我们的军队是一场灾难。我们的医疗保健是一场恐怖表演。奥巴马医改，我们要废除它……”
I got to admit, when I hear stuff like that, I'm like, "yeah! Go! Just yeah, hit him again, harder!" And then I step back and go, wait a minute.
我不得不承认，当我听到这些话时，我就想，“太棒了！加油！就这样，再狠狠地打他一下！”然后我退后一步，心想，等一下。
Do I really want him to be president?
我真的想让他当总统吗？
This is insane because the emotional part of me cannot take control over the thought process that is going to be what carries us in the long run. And that's what scares me about this whole thing. All of this is being wrought out on pure emotion. It's just been building.
这太疯狂了，因为我情感上的那部分无法控制将长期影响我们的思维过程。这就是关于整件事让我害怕的地方。这一切都是出于纯粹的情绪。它一直在积累。
Obama is getting his way. Nobody's standing against him. He's ruining this country. He doesn't love America. And we don't have people that are pushing back. And it just-- that mindset turns, and people get madder and madder. And I'm afraid we're gonna split the party and be in real trouble.
奥巴马为所欲为。没有人反对他。他在毁掉这个国家。他不爱美国。我们没有人在反击。这就——这种心态转变了，人们变得越来越愤怒。我担心我们会分裂党派，陷入真正的困境。
Do you have a specific memory of somebody calling in the show, and you think, oh, wait a minute. This isn't going away.
你对某人打进节目有什么具体的记忆吗，让你觉得，哦，等一下。这件事不会消失了。
Yeah, Barry. Yeah. He called. He calls my show a lot. And I call him the Trump interpreter.
是的，Barry。是的。他打来了。他经常给我的节目打电话。我叫他“特朗普翻译”。
"All right. Barry's on the phone. Hello, Barry."
“好了。Barry在线上。你好，Barry。”
"Hey, Tony. I got a couple questions on the Donald for you."
“嘿，Tony。我对唐纳德有个问题要问你。”
"OK, sure. Go ahead."
“好的，没问题。说吧。”
Barry is an evangelical Christian. He's very strong in his faith. And when he called and was all about Trump, I was like, oh, my gosh.
Barry是一位福音派基督徒。他的信仰非常坚定。当他打来电话全力支持特朗普时，我就想，噢，天哪。
"Now, the pushback that's he's doing against the media, various different reporters, and so forth-- good or bad?"
“那么，他针对媒体、各种不同的记者等等所作出的反击——是好是坏？”
"It's good and bad."
“有好有坏。”
"Donald Trump is bullying--"
“唐纳德·特朗普在欺凌……”
"Bullying."
“欺凌。”
"--the GOP establishment."
“……共和党建制派。”
"Oh. Hm."
“哦。嗯。”
"Is that a good or bad thing?"
“那是好事还是坏事？”
"Well, I think it's a good thing for his campaign. And I think it's a good thing for the people who are tired of the GOP establishment going to Washington and doing squat to make changes."
“嗯，我认为这对他的竞选来说是件好事。我认为这对那些厌倦了共和党建制派去华盛顿却什么都不做来推动变革的人来说是件好事。”
"Sounds like you're on the Trump train."
“听起来你在特朗普的列车上。”
"No. I'm not on the Trump train."
“不。我不在特朗普的列车上。”
"Then what's going on?"
“那到底是怎么回事？”
"I didn't say that he's not doing things that are helpful."
“我没说他没做有帮助的事情。”
"I know. I know."
“我知道。我知道。”
"And I'm saying-- look, what I'm saying is, I don't want to get into all the reasons why I think it's a problem. But anyway, Barry, thanks. We don't have time. We got to take a break. We'll come back. We've got a couple of guests in the studios we want to--"
“我想说的是——听着，我想说的是，我不想深入探讨我认为这是个问题的所有原因。但总之，Barry，谢谢。我们没时间了。我们得休息一下。回来后，我们演播室里有几位嘉宾想……”
Notice how much Tony and Barry agree on. The media is unfair to their candidates. The Republican establishment dismisses them. But still--
注意到Tony和Barry达成一致的地方有多多了吧。媒体对他们的候选人不公平。共和党建制派不理睬他们。但即便如此——
So you've gotten to know Barry.
所以你已经了解Barry了。
Well, I wouldn't recognize him if he walked in the room. But I've talked to him enough on the air where, over the years-- I mean, he's been calling this show for years. And I felt like I knew him pretty well. But he's gone in a direction that I would have said wouldn't have happened.
嗯，如果他走进房间我肯定认不出他。但我已经在节目里和他谈过足够多次了，多年来——我的意思是，他给节目打过很多年的电话。我觉得我很了解他。但他走上了一个我本来会说绝不会发生的道路。
I thought we agreed that the person that we wanted to lead us would agree with our principles and have that at their core. So you're willing to lay all that aside? Oh, I think he has those principles whether he's a Christian or not. I just raise the white flag and go, line two because I don't know what to do about that.
我以为我们同意我们想要的领导人会认同我们的原则，并以这些为核心。所以你愿意把这一切都抛诸脑后？哦，我认为他拥有这些原则，无论他是不是基督徒。我只是举起白旗，说，接线员，因为我不知道该怎么处理这个问题。
So after months of squabbling with Barry and the other callers over Trump, Tony remembers vividly the moment he was sure the ongoing argument with his listeners would finally end. It was the moment he was sure Trump had lost the evangelical vote. It was when Trump said we needed to ban all Muslims from coming to America.
所以在与Barry和其他听众为特朗普争吵了几个月后，Tony清晰地记得那个让他确信与听众持续不断的争论终将结束的时刻。那是特朗普说我们需要禁止所有穆斯林进入美国的时候。
My first thought was, no. That-- no. Somebody's got that messed up. So then I find a video where he actually makes that statement.
我最初的想法是，不。这——不。有人搞错了。所以我找到了他发表这一声明的视频。
Donald J. Trump is calling for a total and complete shutdown of Muslims entering the United States until our country's representatives can figure out what the hell is going on.
唐纳德·J·特朗普呼吁全面、彻底地停止穆斯林进入美国，直到我们国家的代表能够弄清楚到底发生了什么事。
And I was horrified. You want to know my initial reaction? I was horrified. I'm thinking to myself, this is so opposed to everything that are my core values.
我感到震惊。你想知道我最初的反应吗？我感到震惊。我心想，这与我所有核心价值观完全背道而驰。
Were you nervous to come in and do the show after that happened because you knew--
那件事发生后，你去主持节目时紧张吗，因为你知道——
No, because I'm an idiot. Because I came in and thought, man, this may help Trump overall. But Christians, they're going to be appalled by this.
不，因为我是个白痴。因为我走进来时心想，伙计，这可能会整体上帮助特朗普。但基督徒们，他们会对这个感到震惊的。
Barry's on the line. Go ahead, Barry.
Barry在线上。继续吧，Barry。
He didn't say their religious expression. He said Muslims, which--
他没有说他们的宗教表达。他说的是穆斯林，这——
It's a religion!
这是一个宗教！
Their ideology is absolutely a conquering ideology. But--
他们的意识形态绝对是一种征服的意识形态。但是——
He's saying Muslims have a conquering ideology.
他说穆斯林有一种征服的意识形态。
--until we can find out what's going on. So, you know--
——直到我们能查清楚发生了什么。所以，你知道——
OK. Well, why don't we ban Christians? Why don't we-- you know, Christians have in their background an ideological conquering mentality. I mean, you look at that Old Testament, man, you've got the Jews that were taking over the entire country. Christianity rose out of Judaism in the Christian-- now, I'm talking. I'm talking now, Barry. See, this is the way this works. We don't talk at the same time.
好吧。那我们为什么要禁止基督徒？为什么我们——你知道，基督徒在他们的背景中也有意识形态上的征服心态。我是说，你看看那本《旧约》，伙计，那些犹太人占领了整个国家。基督教从犹太教中兴起——现在我在说，我现在在说，Barry。看，这就是运作方式。我们不能同时说话。
So we need to be-- what I'm trying to get you to see is that once we start down a road where we tell people that because of their religious expression, we're going to deny them entry into the country, we're setting a precedent.
所以我们需要——我正试图让你看到的是，一旦我们开始走上一条路，告诉人们因为他们的宗教表达，我们要拒绝他们进入这个国家，我们就设立了一个先例。
Yeah, I disagree because that's not what he's saying. It's their ideology. It's the connection with terror is what he's talking about.
是的，我不同意，因为那不是他在说的。是他们的意识形态。他谈论的是与恐怖活动的联系。
But all Muslims are not terrorist. All Muslims are not terrorist. All Christians don't shoot abortion doctors and bomb abortion clinics. I don't want to get lumped in with them because I'm a Christian any more than there are Muslims that don't want to be lumped into the idea of terrorism because there are radical Islamic extremists who are trying to kill people. Barry, thanks for the call.
但并非所有穆斯林都是恐怖分子。并非所有穆斯林都是恐怖分子。并非所有基督徒都会射杀堕胎医生和炸毁堕胎诊所。我不想因为我是基督徒就和他们混为一谈，正如那些不想因为存在试图杀人的极端伊斯兰主义者就被混为一谈的穆斯林一样。Barry，谢谢你的致电。
Robbie, I'm gonna have to hold you. We got to take a break. We'll come back. We'll talk to Robbie.
Robbie，我得让你等一下。我们得休息一下。回来后我们和Robbie聊。
So I went to Barry, in person, to understand, yes, why he loves Trump so much, but really, how he'd strayed so far from Tony.
所以我亲自去见了Barry，想了解，是的，为什么他那么爱特朗普，但更重要的是，他是如何偏离Tony那么远的。
Is it you?
是你吗？
Hello, there. How are you?
你好。你好吗？
Hi, Barry.
你好，Barry。
This is my son, David.
这是我儿子，David。
I'm Zoe. It's just, I'm thrilled to meet you. You're like a celebrity to me.
我是Zoe。见到你真是太激动了。对我来说，你就像个名人。
Oh, really? I don't understand. How's that? I don't get it.
哦，真的吗？我不明白。怎么会呢？我不懂。
Barry Chisholm, in the flesh. He works 20 minutes away from Tony's radio studio. He runs a small business managing employee benefits. This means he is up close and personal with Obamacare, which he is not a fan of. Barry is what you might have pictured-- hyper, older white guy in a baseball cap. He is indeed an evangelical Christian from Boston. It takes him just a few seconds to wind himself up.
Barry Chisholm，本人。他在离Tony电台工作室20分钟路程的地方工作。他经营一家管理员工福利的小公司。这意味着他与奥巴马医改近距离接触，他不是那个政策的粉丝。Barry就是你可能想象的那样——一个戴棒球帽、精力充沛的年长白人。他确实是一位来自波士顿的福音派基督徒。只需几秒钟他就能进入兴奋状态。
Is that part of why you would move down here? Like, it seems like a more friendly environment to evangelicals than Boston is.
这是你搬到这里的部分原因吗？看起来这里对福音派比波士顿更友好。
No, actually. No, I miss being up in Boston because the difference up there is if you're a Christian, you stand out like crazy. If you're a Christian down here, it's a cultural thing. And I like being around people that have strong opinions because it's fun. Because you know what? I know what I believe. And what I believe is not what I made up. It's this guy Jesus Christ who started it. So I'm globbing on to what he taught.
不，实际上。不，我很怀念波士顿，因为那里的不同之处在于，如果你是基督徒，你会非常突出。如果你在这里是基督徒，这是一种文化氛围。我喜欢和有强烈观点的人在一起，因为这很有趣。因为你知道吗？我知道我信仰什么。我所信仰的不是我自己编出来的。而是这个叫耶稣基督的人，他开启了这一切。所以我只是坚持他所教导的。
So it's fun. I miss being up around people who don't know about Christ and what he taught. So no, I miss that. That's probably the most fun part, is I like to engage people. And I like to turn people on. Hey, go check it out. If you don't believe me, go find out for yourself. That's the journey I had to take. And so no, I would never move down here just because--
所以这很有趣。我怀念那些不知道基督及其教导的人。所以不，我怀念那一点。那可能是最有趣的部分，我喜欢与人互动。我喜欢激励人们。嘿，去查查吧。如果你不信我，自己去查。那就是我必须走的旅程。所以不，我绝不会仅仅因为这个就搬到这里——
So, I mean, also, it sounds like you kind of like living a little bit as a contrarian. Is that fair to say?
那么，我的意思是，听起来你也有一点喜欢活得像个反主流的人。这么说公平吗？
Yeah, that's real kind of accurate. You know? Yeah, it is kind of accurate, I guess. I mean, yeah.
是的，那确实很准确。你知道吗？是的，我想那确实很准确。我是说，是的。
Barry is the guy who loves to stir the pot. Barry is a mischief maker. He is a scamp, kind of like Donald Trump. Tony and Barry, though, they started out this election season in the very same place.
Barry是个喜欢搅局的人。Barry是个捣蛋鬼。他是个顽童，有点像唐纳德·特朗普。不过，Tony和Barry在竞选季开始时处于同一个地方。
Well, I mean, I supported the Huck-- Mike Huckabee, Rick Santorum before that, and then held my nose and voted for Mitt Romney. And I way back supported Reagan. So when this came around, and you had not the seven dwarfs, the 14 dwarfs out there, I mean, I just waited to see all the dust settle.
好吧，我是说，我之前支持过Huckabee、Rick Santorum，然后捏着鼻子投了Mitt Romney的票。我很久以前支持过里根。所以当这次竞选到来，有那14个小矮人出来时，我只是在等尘埃落定。
One thing about Donald Trump, I said, it will be entertaining if he gets in. It will be fun to watch because he's not a politician. I didn't realize how much fun it would be. But it's gone way beyond my expectations. It's been the most enjoyable election I've ever seen, watching all these people's heads implode. It's been a fun time.
关于唐纳德·特朗普有一点，我说，如果他进去了会很有趣。看着会很有意思，因为他不是个政治家。我没想到会这么有趣。但这远远超出了我的预期。这是我看过最令人愉快的选举，看着所有人的脑袋爆炸。这是段有趣的时光。
It's been fun to watch all the establishments come unhinged because they can't control it. It's fun to watch the liberal media come out with the big hits, the names, and he's this, he's racist, and all that. I just never knew someone could take the heat and just punch back. So it's like, yeah, this is fun. This is different.
看着所有建制派因为无法控制局面而崩溃很有意思。看着自由派媒体拿出大牌攻击他，说他是种族主义者之类的，很有意思。我从来没见过有人能承受压力并反击。所以就像，是的，这很有趣。这不一样。
As for Ted Cruz, Barry says, forget it. He'd be killed in the mainstream media. He saw it with other strong evangelical candidates. They will just make fun of him.
至于Ted Cruz，Barry说，算了吧。他会在主流媒体中被毁掉。他已经在其他强大的福音派候选人身上看到了。他们只会嘲笑他。
But Donald Trump, he'll make fun of the mainstream media. That is such a joy to Barry. By the time the first debate happened-- you know, Megyn Kelly, the Rosie O'Donnell question-- Barry and Tony had completely opposite experiences. Tony's like, are you kidding me about Trump? But that's what Barry says about Megyn Kelly.
但唐纳德·特朗普，他会嘲笑主流媒体。这对Barry来说是如此快乐。当第一次辩论发生时——你知道，Megyn Kelly，那个罗西·奥唐奈的问题——Barry和Tony的经历完全相反。Tony想，你在拿特朗普开玩笑吗？但这正是Barry对Megyn Kelly的看法。
Megyn Kelly had to spend a lot of time to dig up that little piece, and he made a cavalier joke. Are you kidding me? She was digging for stuff. We've got so politically correct, just like when Donald Trump said about Carly Fiorina's face. Look at that face. Look, Donald Trump-- look, if you're going to be a woman, you're going to get in the thing, then go for it. Don't be, don't be-- he's an equal opportunity basher. He'll bash guys as well as women. Stop with the baby stuff.
Megyn Kelly必须花很多时间才能挖出那个小片段，而他开了一个随意的玩笑。你在开玩笑吗？她是在挖掘素材。我们变得如此政治正确，就像唐纳德·特朗普评价Carly Fiorina的脸一样。看看那张脸。看，唐纳德·特朗普——看，如果你要当女人，你要参与这件事，那就去吧。别……别……他是个机会均等的批评者。他既批评男人也批评女人。别再玩那些小儿科了。
And the Megyn Kelly thing, it became more about her than-- this is a presidential debate.
而Megyn Kelly的事情，它变成了关于她个人的事，而不是——这是一场总统辩论。
Didn't he say, blood coming out of her wherever?
他不是说，血从她的各个地方流出来吗？
Oh, that. Oh, that, too. And that-- oh, that was afterwards. Yeah, oh yeah. That was stupidity. I mean, there's no doubt about it. You know, is all this stuff presidential? I don't know. But you know what, this guy's not a politician.
哦，那个。哦，那个也是。那是——哦，那是之后发生的。是的，哦是的。那是愚蠢。我是说，毫无疑问。你知道，这一切都是总统该有的样子吗？我不知道。但你知道吗，这家伙不是政治家。
Megyn Kelly, the wall, the ban on Muslims, all the stuff that Tony was sure would drive everyone away, Barry loves those things. Barry loves the idea, not necessarily the practice, but the fact of the statement of banning all Muslims.
Megyn Kelly，墙，禁止穆斯林，所有Tony确信会把每个人赶走的东西，Barry都喜欢。Barry喜欢那个想法，不一定是实践，而是禁止所有穆斯林的声明本身。
All he's bringing up is do we have a problem? And if we do, can we talk about it? Or are we gonna just, everybody's a bigot now. I mean, that's all. So Donald Trump-- we just want-- it needs to be addressed.
他提出来的一切就是我们是否有问题？如果有，我们能谈谈吗？还是我们都要变成偏执狂？我是说，就是这样。所以唐纳德·特朗普——我们只是想——这需要被解决。
What I found out upon meeting Barry is one of the things he loves most about Donald Trump is arguing about Donald Trump. The conversation that is freaking Tony out so much about the state of the country, that conversation itself is the thing that Barry is relishing.
我遇到Barry后发现，他最喜欢唐纳德·特朗普的事情之一就是争论唐纳德·特朗普。那场让Tony对国家现状如此惊恐的对话，那场对话本身就是Barry正在享受的事情。
And Barry's diabolical about it. Barry has eight sons, all Trump fans, he says. And he's deployed his son David in his pro-Trump battles against Tony.
而且Barry在这一点上表现得很邪恶。Barry有八个儿子，都是特朗普的粉丝，他说。他派他的儿子David在支持特朗普的战斗中去对抗Tony。
What'll happen is, my dad will get on there. Tony will get all flustered and upset. And every once in a while, if he's having a bad day, he'll cut him off short. So then I call right in and just kind of continue the conversation because he thinks it's a whole 'nother caller or--
发生的情况是，我爸爸会打进去。Tony会变得很慌乱和不安。每隔一段时间，如果他心情不好，他就会粗暴地挂断电话。然后我就直接打进去，继续谈话，因为他以为这是另一个听众或者——
It is.
确实是。
It is. But the whole-- so he can't avoid the Trump mindset sometimes.
确实是。但他整个人——所以他有时无法避免特朗普的心态。
Why do you do that to him?
你为什么要对他那样做？
It's just the challenge of it. Because they have the authority to just kick people off and make people feel stupid when they call in. A lot of people be like, well, I don't really like Trump. I'm not a Trump supporter, but, you know, he's pretty good on this issue. And Tony will be just, oh! Jump all over that.
这只是挑战。因为他们有权力随便挂断人们的电话，让人在打进去时感到愚蠢。很多人会说，嗯，我不太喜欢特朗普。我不是特朗普的支持者，但是，你知道，他在这个问题上表现得不错。而Tony就会，哦！猛扑过去。
I thought the Trump supporters I'd meet in South Carolina would be angry. But a lot of them are like Barry-- angry, but having such a great time. The people I met, they're more happy than angry. Like at this biker rally for Trump.
我以为我在南卡罗来纳州见到的特朗普支持者会很愤怒。但他们很多人像Barry一样——愤怒，却玩得非常开心。我遇到的人们，他们比愤怒更快乐。就像在这个特朗普的骑行者集会上。
Thanks everybody coming out for this. We're going to line our bikes up facing Market Common. So when he comes through, we're going to be about an eighth mile wide. And he'll be able to see us, see what's going on. If you're a felon or anything, leave your guns behind. You never know. They might have Secret Service there. You got a permit, by all means carry it.
谢谢大家出来参加这个。我们将把摩托车排成一行，面向Market Common。所以当他经过时，我们将有大约八分之一英里宽。他将能够看到我们，看到发生了什么。如果你是重罪犯什么的，把枪留下。你永远不知道。他们可能有特勤局在那里。你有许可证，一定要带上。
That's all I got. Thanks everybody coming out.
这就是我所有的了。谢谢大家出来。
[CHANTING "TRUMP"]
（高呼“特朗普”）
The rally was held at a biker bar in Myrtle Beach called Suck Bang Blow. It was explained to me that those are the mechanics of a combustion engine. I asked this guy Kool-Aid about Trump-- leather vest and tattoos.
集会在Myrtle Beach的一家骑行者酒吧举行，名叫“吸、砰、吹”。有人向我解释说那是内燃机的运作原理。我问这家伙Kool-Aid关于特朗普的事——穿着皮背心和纹身。
So why do you like Trump so much?
所以你为什么那么喜欢特朗普？
Well, because, I mean, he's just down to Earth. I know he's kind of loud and obnoxious. But so are all of us bikers.
嗯，因为，我的意思是，他就是脚踏实地。我知道他有点吵闹和令人讨厌。但我们骑行者也一样。
Kool-Aid's never voted in his life. Today, he's throwing a Trump rally to welcome him to town. And he has voter registration cards stacked up at the bar. Steve, he'd never voted before, either.
Kool-Aid这辈子从没投过票。今天，他正在举行特朗普集会来欢迎他来到镇上。他在吧台上堆满了选民登记卡。Steve，他以前也从没投过票。
Never ever did I give two craps who ran because I figure we're gonna get screwed anyway. But there's a difference now.
我从来不在乎谁竞选，因为我觉得无论如何我们都会被坑。但现在不同了。
When did you register?
你什么时候登记的？
Three days ago.
三天前。
For Trump?
为了特朗普？
Absolutely. Just figured I got to do it because, you know what? Every little bit helps. My one vote might not be much, but you know what? It might be the one that makes it rock.
绝对的。只是觉得我必须这样做，因为，你知道吗？每一分力量都有帮助。我的一票可能不多，但你知道吗？它可能是让它动摇的那一票。
I went registered last week so I can vote me some Trump.
我上周去登记了，这样我就可以投我的特朗普一票。
Vote me some Trump?
投你的特朗普一票？
Heck, yeah. We need somebody, or it's going to hell in a hand basket.
见鬼，是的。我们需要某个人，否则一切都要下地狱了。
I knew these guys, first time voters, wouldn't care that they might split the Republican Party. They never felt at home there. But Barry, Tony's radio nemesis/radio frenemy, is different. So I asked him, if you go for Trump, are you going to split the party?
我知道这些家伙，第一次投票的人，不会在乎他们是否会分裂共和党。他们从来没有在那里感到宾至如归。但Barry，Tony的电台宿敌/电台损友，是不一样的。所以我问他，如果你支持特朗普，你会分裂党派吗？
Who cares? I don't care. The Republican Party needed to be split a long time ago. They troll the evangelicals. They pandered to the conservatives. And when they get in there, they do what their lobbyists tell them to do. So if the Republican Party splits, so what? All I care about America at the end of the day.
谁在乎？我不在乎。共和党早该分裂了。他们利用福音派。他们迎合保守派。当他们进入那里时，他们做游说者告诉他们做的事情。所以如果共和党分裂了，那又怎样？归根结底，我只关心美国。
Tony, though, really cares. He does not want to lose the election. And he wonders, what does it mean about his listeners if they follow this pied piper?
不过，Tony真的很在乎。他不想输掉选举。他想知道，如果他们跟随这个吹笛人，这对他的听众意味着什么？
I think that's what's led to my current level of frustration. And I admit to you that it's greater than in the past. And I probably, quite frankly, need to dial it back a little bit because I don't need to be consumed by this. And for the last couple of weeks, I've probably been-- I mean, this has been very heavy on my mind.
我认为这就是导致我目前挫败感的原因。我承认这比过去要大。坦率地说，我可能需要稍微调低一点，因为我不需要被这个消耗。过去几周，我可能一直——我是说，这件事一直沉重地压在我的心头。
And then he has this other worry, this other way of thinking about it. This worry is so personal, at first he didn't want to talk about it.
然后他还有这个其他的担忧，这种思考方式。这个担忧太私人了，起初他不想谈论它。
I want to tell you something off the record.
我想告诉你一些私下的事。
Oh, OK. Oh.
哦，好的。哦。
But after we talked a little, he agreed to go back on mic.
但在我们交谈了一会儿后，他同意继续录音。
I mean, there've been times when I've thought about just giving up the radio show because I don't want to be one who fosters the unreasonable level of anger that's out there.
我是说，有几次我想过放弃这个电台节目，因为我不想成为那个助长外面那种不合理愤怒程度的人。
Do you think that by giving airtime to some of this stuff--
你认为通过给这些东西播出时间——
Well, I have callers who call in that are very angry now. And they express things that-- and I push back. But I just wonder how many people are hearing that and going, he's right. And Dr. Beam needs to get with the program. You know?
嗯，我有打进电话的听众，他们现在非常愤怒。他们表达了一些东西——而我进行了回击。但我只是想知道有多少人听到这些心想，他是对的。Beam博士需要跟上进度。你知道吗？
And so I debate sometimes with myself, am I not doing anything except giving a platform? Look, Jesus Christ, when he walked this earth, condemned the zealots. He condemned the establishment, the Pharisees and the Sadducees, because they were hypocrites.
所以我有时会自我辩论，我是不是什么都没做，只是提供了一个平台？看，耶稣基督，当他走在这地球上时，他谴责了狂热分子。他谴责了建制派，法利赛人和撒都该人，因为他们是伪君子。
But he also condemned those who wanted to march against Rome in a violent way. That was not the path that Jesus talked about. Jesus was the Prince of Peace. He was a reconciler. I know that's what he's done in my life.
但他也谴责那些想要以暴力方式对抗罗马的人。那不是耶稣谈论的道路。耶稣是和平之君。他是和解者。我知道这就是他在我生命中所做的事。
And I want to be that to represent him in the world. I don't want to be somebody that pours gas on a fire. I want to be a reconciler who brings peace in a situation where anger seems to be the prevailing thought process. And I don't know how best to do that.
我想代表他在世界上成为那样的人。我不想成为那个火上浇油的人。我想成为一个和解者，在愤怒似乎是主导思维过程的情况下带来和平。我不知道最好的做法是什么。
But if I can't do it with a microphone, I'd just rather turn it off. It's not Trump that bothers me. What bothers me is that Trump is popular.
但如果我不能用麦克风做到这一点，我宁愿关掉它。困扰我的不是特朗普。困扰我的是特朗普很受欢迎。
That story from Zoe Chace, one of the produces of our show. She'll be doing campaign coverage for us all this year. Coming up, mistaking a guy who does exist for one who does not exist. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
那个来自Zoe Chace的故事，我们节目的制作人之一。她今年将为我们进行竞选报道。接下来，把一个真实存在的人错认成不存在的人。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续时一分钟后播出。
This is American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, I Thought I Knew You-- stories of people misperceiving other people. Sometimes it slowly dawns on them that they have it wrong. Sometimes it comes out quickly. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, My Little Bruce Dupe.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，带来关于这个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，我以为我认识你——关于人们误解他人的故事。有时他们会慢慢意识到自己错了。有时很快就会真相大白。我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，我的小布鲁斯骗局。
Well, so far on our program, we have focused on people who are misperceived. But they don't want to be misperceived. They're not doing things to create misperceptions. But, of course, sometimes people deliberately mislead other people about who they are. Comedian Jay Larson has this example--
好吧，到目前为止在我们的节目中，我们关注的是被误解的人。但他们不想被误解。他们并没有做什么来制造误解。但当然，有时人们会故意误导他人关于他们是谁。喜剧演员Jay Larson就有这样一个例子——
Your cell phone rings. You don't recognize the number. What do you do?
你的手机响了。你不认识这个号码。你做什么？
Ignore it!
忽略它！
Ignore it. Send it to voicemail. Yeah. Not this guy. I answer it. Yeah, exactly. Opportunity, potential, who knows? Who knows what it is?
忽略它。发到语音信箱。是的。不是这家伙。我接听。是的，完全正确。机会，潜力，谁知道呢？谁知道它是什么？
The other day, I was driving down the 405. Traffic. Phone rings. 917, New York. I'm like, ooh, I don't know the number. I hit talk. I go, "hello?" Guy on the other line goes, "hey, Bruce. What's going on?"
那天，我开在405公路上。交通堵塞。电话响了。917，纽约。我心想，哦，我不认识这个号码。我按了通话。我说，“喂？”对方那个人说，“嘿，Bruce。最近怎么样？”
My name's Jay, not Bruce. So clearly, "I go, nothing much, man. What's going on with you?"
我叫Jay，不叫Bruce。所以很明显，“我说，没啥，伙计。你怎么样？”
And he goes, "I'll tell you what's going on. I just got an email about the budget. It's supposed to be $15,000. Now it's $10,000. I'd like to know what the hell's going on."
他说，“我告诉你发生了什么。我刚收到一封关于预算的邮件。它应该是1.5万美元。现在是1万美元。我想知道到底发生了什么。”
And I grabbed the steering wheel. It was like, all right. Focus. Focus right now. Your name is Bruce. There's a budget. It's $15,000. Now it's $10,000. No one's happy about it. Just go with this. Go with this.
我抓住了方向盘。就像是，好的。专注。现在专注。你的名字是Bruce。有一个预算。它是1.5万美元。现在是1万美元。没有人对此感到高兴。顺着这个思路走。顺着这个走。
I didn't know much. I only knew what he told me. So I just said it back. And I go, "$10,000? It's supposed to be $15,000!"
我知道的不多。我只知道他告诉我的。所以我只是重复了一遍。我说，“1万美元？它应该是1.5万美元！”
He goes, "yeah, well, I just got an email, and now it's $10,000."
他说，“是的，好吧，我刚收到一封邮件，现在它是1万美元。”
And I go, "hey, I don't know what to tell you, man. I'm on the road right now. I haven't even seen the email."
我说，“嘿，我不知道该怎么告诉你，伙计。我现在在路上。我甚至还没看到那封邮件。”
And he goes, "are you behind this? Did you send it out?" Like giving Bruce some attitude, you know what I mean?
他说，“是你搞的鬼吗？是你发出来的吗？”就像是在给Bruce摆脸色，你知道我的意思吗？
And I'm like, "no way I am taking that. There's no way."
我说，“我绝对不会背这个锅。绝不可能。”
And I go, "listen, bro. The budget was $15,000. We had a couple extra expenditures. It went up to $16,200. I reworked it, got it down to $14,700. We had $300 to play with. I called it $15,000. I sent it out."
我说，“听着，兄弟。预算是1.5万美元。我们有一些额外的开支。它涨到了1.62万美元。我重新做了预算，把它降到了1.47万美元。我们有300美元的余地。我叫它1.5万美元。我把它发了出去。”
He goes, "yeah? Well, now it's $10,000!"
他说，“是吗？好吧，现在是1万美元！”
And I was like, "oh, my God! That worked!" Stay focused. Stay focused I'm not even enjoying it. You know what I mean? Because I can't even laugh. I have to stay-- I'm, like, literally in it. I was just in it.
我说，“噢，天哪！起作用了！”保持专注。保持专注。我甚至还没享受它。你知道我的意思吗？因为我甚至不能笑。我必须保持——我简直，简直就在戏里。我刚才就在戏里。
He goes, "did Larry OK this?" Now he's throwing Larry at me. Yeah.
他说，“Larry批准了吗？”现在他拿Larry压我。是的。
So I go, "listen. I took it to Larry. He said it looked fine. But I knew it was my ass on the line, so I ran it by Jennifer just in case. She said it looked good. I sent it out."
所以我说，“听着。我把它带给Larry看了。他说看起来不错。但我知道这是我的屁股在冒火，所以我又跑去让Jennifer看了一眼以防万一。她说看起来很好。我就发了出去。”
He goes, "yeah? Well, now it's $10,000!"
他说，“是吗？好吧，现在是1万美元！”
And I was like, this guy has no idea what's going on over there. He hasn't talked to Larry. He hasn't talked to Jennifer. I just made her up. Clearly, he has not spoken to Bruce.
我说，这家伙根本不知道那边发生了什么。他没跟Larry谈过。他没跟Jennifer谈过。那是我编出来的。显然，他没跟Bruce谈过。
He goes, "listen, man. What are we gonna do about this?"
他说，“听着，伙计。我们打算对此做什么？”
I go, "bro, I'm on the road right now. I haven't even seen the email. Why don't you call Larry, check in with him? See what's going on, give me a call back." Literally like throwing the fishing line out, being like, please say yes because that phone call return is going to be amazing.
我说，“兄弟，我现在在路上。我甚至还没看到邮件。你为什么不给Larry打个电话，问问他？看看发生了什么，再给我回个电话。”简直就像抛出鱼线一样，心里想，请答应吧，因为那个回电会很棒。
And he goes, "listen. Why don't we wait till you get home. You check the email. You call Larry. You call me back."
他说，“好的。”挂了电话，我欣喜若狂，因为纽约某处有一家小公司正因为5000美元而分崩离析。没人能找到Bruce。没人跟Larry谈过。而且他们不知道Jennifer是谁。太刺激了。
I go, "no, no, bro. Larry knows way more about this than I do. Give him a call, call me back."
（欢呼）
He goes, "OK." Hangs up the phone, to which I explode with euphoria because there's a small business in New York somewhere that's crumbling to the ground over $5,000. No one can find Bruce. No one's talked to Larry. And they don't know who the hell Jennifer is. Excitement.
还没完。我回到家。我太兴奋了。我给朋友们打电话，告诉他们发生了什么。我对自己说，你知道吗？我要保存那个家伙的号码，过几天给他打个电话。联系一下，摸摸底。看看我们进展到哪了。我把号码保存在手机里，存成了“随机家伙”。他是个随机家伙。
[CHEERING]
我没多想。几天过去了。没大事。躺在沙发上看比赛。电话响了，在餐桌上。看着比赛。起身，拿起电话，往下看——“随机家伙”。
Not even done. I get home. I'm so excited. I call some friends, tell them what happened. I think to myself, you know what? I'm going to save that guy's number, give him a call in a couple days. Check in, touch base. See where we're at. I save the number on my phone under Random Guy. He's a random guy.
我对自己说，“随机家伙”？我不认识什么“随机家伙”。谁他妈是“随机家伙”？然后我心想，噢！“随机家伙”！
I don't think about it. A couple days pass. No big deal. Laying on the couch, watching the game. Phone rings, dining room table. Watching the game. Get up, pick up the phone, look down-- Random Guy.
现在我吓坏了。你知道我的意思吗？我在家里。他们知道我在哪。人们的生活受到了影响。
And I think to myself, Random Guy? I don't know any Random Guy. Who the hell's Random Guy? And then I was like, oh! Random Guy!
但这才是我的作风。你知道我的意思吗？是我发起的这件事。我要把它演到结局。我就是这么看这件事的。戴上耳塞，保持一点距离。保持一点距离，你知道我的意思吗？
Now I'm freaked out. You know what I mean? I'm in my house. They know where I'm at. People's lives have been affected.
我按下通话。我说，“喂？”同一个人说，“嘿，Larry，最近怎么样？”现在他叫我Larry了。他知道怎么回事了。但我不会屈服。你知道我的意思吗？
But this is who I am. You know what I mean? I started this thing. I'm going to see it through the end. That's how I saw this. Put in my ear buds, just get a little distance. Just get some distance, you know I mean?
我说，“没啥，伙计。你怎么样？”他说，“听着，我让我们跟Jenelle和Marie开了电话会议。”好像我会向Jenelle和Marie退缩一样。
I hit Talk. I go, "hello?" Same guy goes, "hey, Larry, what's going on?" Now he's calling me Larry. He knows what's up. But I'm not gonna cave. You know what I mean?
所以我说，呃，“嘿女士们。欢迎参加会议——”就好像在说，欢迎来到节目。我们开始吧。我们要撒谎多久？你想让我撒谎多久？因为我会奉陪到底。
And I go, "nothing much, man. What's going on with you?" And he goes, "listen, I got us on conference call with Jenelle and Marie." Like I'm backing down from Jenelle and Marie.
Marie，她带头了。她说，“嘿，Larry。你那边几点了？”我看了看钟，是5:30。他们是一家纽约公司。
So I go, uh, "hey ladies. Welcome to the call--" as if to say, welcome to the show. Here we go. How long are we going to lie for? How long do you want me to lie? Because I'm going to go all the way.
所以我说，“8:30。现在是8:30。”就好像撒更多的谎，好像我能骗过她们。我能骗过她们。
Marie, she takes the lead. She goes, "hey, Larry. What time is it where you are?" And I look at the clock, and it's 5:30. And they're a New York company.
她说，“真的吗？天气怎么样？”我说，“天气不错。天气不错。”
So I go "8:30. It's 8:30." Like, sprinkling more lies and, like, I can fool them. I can fool them.
她说，“真的吗？这听起来不像Larry。”
She goes, "really? What's the weather like?" And I go, "weather's nice. Weather is nice."
我说，“哦，是吗？那听起来像谁？”
She goes, "really? This doesn't sound like Larry."
那个两次打电话的家伙，他尖叫着。他说，“听起来像Bruce！听起来像Bruce！”就好像他要拆穿这个案子。
And I go, "oh, yeah? Who's it sound like?"
我说，“伙计们，这不是Larry，也不是Bruce。”
And the guy who called both times, he chirps in. He's like, "sounds like Bruce! Sounds like Bruce!" Like he's gonna blow this case wide open.
她说，“你是谁？”
And I go, "guys, this isn't Larry and this isn't Bruce."
我当时说，“我只是个除了耍你们之外没事可干的家伙。”Marie不喜欢那样。她生气了。她开始对我大吼大叫。她说，“我们是一家努力经营的小企业！”
And she goes, "who is this?"
我说，“噢，我知道。”
And I was like, "I'm just some dude who had nothing better to do than to mess with you guys." Marie did not like that. She got pissed. She started yelling at me. She's like, "we're a small business trying!"
她说，“你觉得这很有趣吗？”
I'm like, "oh, I know."
我说，“嗯，有一点。”
She's like, "you think this is a joke?"
她说，“让我问你一件事。”
And I was like, "well, a little bit."
我说，“不，让我问你一件事！”
She goes, "let me ask you something."
她说，“什么？”
I go, "no, you let me ask you something!"
我说，“我们的预算进展到哪了？”
And she goes, "what?"
（笑声和掌声）
And I go, "where we at with the budget?"
Jay Larson，录制于洛杉矶的Laugh Factory。很神奇，对吧？他的网站——jaylarsoncomedy.com。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
第三幕，另一面的光芒。我想很多孩子会感到非常震惊——我想用震惊这个词——如果老师是好的，老师是多么了解他们。好的老师可以和你没完没了地谈论班上的某个孩子，他们的优点，他们的缺点。当你还是个学生，并且有一位你尊敬的老师，而老师对你的评价很糟糕时，那种感觉真的非常糟糕，你可能永远没有机会去纠正。Eve Abrams讲述了这个故事。
Jay Larson, recorded at the Laugh Factory in Los Angeles. Amazing, right? His website-- jaylarsoncomedy.com.
我在纽约市的一所叫“邻里学校”的小学教了10年书。那是一所学生直呼老师名字的学校，老师们能真正了解他们的学生——他们的家庭，他们的长处，他们的戏剧性事件。但有时，有一个孩子会脱颖而出。这是一个关于其中一个孩子和他朋友以及他的老师的故事。
Act Three, A Light From the Other Side. I think a lot of kids would be really shocked-- I think the right word is shocked-- at how well their teachers understand them, when teachers are good. Good teachers can talk to you forever about this kid or that kid in their class, their good qualities, their bad qualities. And when you're a student, and there's a teacher you respect, and the teacher thinks badly of you, that is just like a horrible feeling that you may or may not get to correct. Eve Abrams tells this story.
Sofia是老师，也是我的朋友。Lilly多年前曾是我们的学生。她现在16岁了。Lilly的同学Robert也是我们的学生。但他去世了，所以我让Lilly跟你讲讲他。
I taught elementary school for 10 years in New York City at this place called The Neighborhood School. It was one of those schools where students call teachers by their first names and where teachers really get to know their students well-- their families, their strengths, their dramas. But sometimes, one kid stands out. This is a story about one of those kids and his friend and his teacher.
有一段时间，我真的很难告诉人们是谁去世了，因为我不想说“朋友”。我不想说“最好的朋友”，因为那样看起来好像，噢，我的最好朋友，就像——你知道我的意思吗？任何人都可以说他们是他最好的朋友。我是说，他住得离我太近了，所以我们24小时全天候在一起。我们聊一切。
Sofia is the teacher and also a friend of mine. Lilly was our student years ago. She's 16 now. And Lilly's classmate Robert was our student, too. But he's dead, so I'll let Lilly tell you about him.
在我们的学校，每个人都相当安静和乖巧。而且，我不知道。对我来说，他只是看起来与众不同，而且他很有趣。其他人很无聊。
I really had a hard time telling people who had died for a while because I didn't want to say friend. And I didn't want to say best friend because that makes it seem like, my best friend, like-- you know what I mean? And anyone can say that they were his best friend. I mean, he lived so close to me, so we'd hang out 24/7. We talked about everything.
老师从来都不喜欢他。他可能稍微有点无礼。比如，他不写作业。那是个大问题，因为在邻里学校，每个人都像，“噢，必须写作业。必须写作业，不然你不能去课间休息，”诸如此类。我是说，随他吧。他会，就像，从不去课间休息，因为他从不写作业。
In our school, everyone was pretty quiet and good. And, like, I don't know. To me, he just seemed like he was just different, and he was fun. And everyone else was boring.
Robert不顺从成年人。其他孩子被这一点吸引。但他也是那种有点不幸的人。他是那种逃课就会被抓到的孩子。
Teachers never liked him. He was probably a little bit rude. Like, he didn't do his homework. That was a big thing because in the Neighborhood School, everyone was like, "oh, got to do your homework. Got to do your homework, or you're not going to go out for recess" and all this stuff. I mean, whatever. He'd be, like, never going out for recess because he never did his homework.
他被中学开除了，这对我来说总是很奇怪，因为有那么多比他糟糕得多的孩子。我是说，有孩子一周来一次，10点钟，抓个女孩就走了。
Robert didn't defer to adults. And other kids were drawn to that. But he was also sort of hapless. He was the kind of kid who when he cut school got caught.
我第一眼看到他时就暗恋他。五年级是我真正深深暗恋他的那一年。就好像，噢，天哪。我爱你。
He got kicked out of middle school, which was always, like, really weird to me because there were so many kids that were so much worse. I mean, there was kids that came in that school like once a week at 10 o'clock and grabbed a girl and left.
有一次他在我门口给我留了花——那是我的生日——然后敲了敲门跑开了。所以我打开门，有花。我当时就想，噢，天哪。噢，天哪。他爱我！就像，花。
I had a crush on him, like, the second I saw him. Fifth grade was the big year that I really had a big crush on him. It was just like, oh, my god. I love you.
所以我捡起来。上面有一张纸条。写着：从Robert给Lilly。生日快乐。顺便说一句，别太高兴，就像是，随你怎么想。别太高兴。别觉得我喜欢你因为我做了这个。别太高兴。我当时想，但我很高兴，因为你给我留了花。
He one time left me flowers at my door-- it was my birthday-- and knocked on the door and ran away. And so I opened the door, and there was flowers. And I was just like, oh, my god. Oh, my god. He loves me! Like, flowers.
我意识到这其实是因为我真的很喜欢他这个朋友。我从来没真正有过一个我这么喜欢的男性朋友。所以我以为我一定爱上他了，或者我一定有那个——但你知道，这也是因为我其实一直很喜欢他这个人。
And so I picked it up. And there was a note. And it said from Robert to Lilly. Happy birthday. PS, don't get happy, as in, like, whatever. Don't get happy. Don't think I like you because I'm doing this. Don't get happy. I was like, but I am happy 'cause you left me flowers.
这就是Lilly眼中的Robert。Sofia眼中的他则不同。在我的班上待过之后，Robert转到了隔壁Sofia的班上。很多时候，我会在走廊里看到并听到他们在一起。大多数时候，我听到的是Sofia。她会对Robert进行关于作业、努力和态度的说教，她的声音变得非常大且恼火。当Sofia说教时，Robert只是站在那儿。
I realized it's actually because I liked him so much as a friend. And I never really had somebody that was a boy that I like so much as a friend. So I figured I must be in love with him or I must have the-- but, you know, it's also like I just actually always really liked him as a person.
翻着白眼。我是说，这更多是一种身体表现。有点在听我说话，但并不是真的在听，有点看向远方，头斜着，双臂交叉，有点在等这集结束。
That's how Lilly saw Robert. Sofia saw him differently. After he was in my class, Robert moved on to Sofia's class right next door. And a lot of times, I'd see and hear them out in the hall together. Mostly, I'd hear Sofia. She would lecture Robert about homework and effort and attitude, and her voice got really loud and annoyed. While Sofia lectured, Robert just stood there.
Sofia比我更难应付Robert。当她教他时他已经更大了，但他的阅读水平并没有好多少。他仍然在功课上挣扎。他也变得非常擅长抵挡老师们尝试的一切——命令、劝诱、欺骗。Sofia会在放学后在街区看到Robert，和年纪较大的男孩混在一起，无所事事。这让她无比沮丧，因为这个聪明、迷人的孩子似乎注定一生都要做死工资的工作和经历失望。
Rolling his eyes. I mean, it was more a physical manifestation. Just kind of listening to me, but not really listening, kind of looking off in the distance, head was at a tilt, arms crossed, kind of waiting for the episode to end.
有一次，当我快要忍无可忍的时候，我和他的家人谈过，让他放学后留在教室里，只是为了让他完成作业。我想我们坚持了一两周。我不认为这很成功。这不是他在家里能复制的习惯。
Sofia had a harder time with Robert than I did. He was older by the time she taught him, but his reading wasn't much better. And he still struggled with his schoolwork. He'd also gotten really good at deflecting all of the things that teachers would try-- ordering, cajoling, tricking. Sofia would see Robert around the neighborhood after school, hanging out with older boys, doing nothing much. And it frustrated her to no end that this smart, charming kid seemed headed for a lifetime of dead-end jobs and disappointments.
Sofia和Robert之间的冲突不断堆积，那一年他们过得很不愉快。有人在学校墙上写了侮辱Sofia的话，写得很高，只有个子高的孩子才能写。而我们的校长深信是Robert写的。他最终被禁止参加毕业大派对。当Robert没在毕业典礼上露面时，学校里的其他孩子，包括Lilly，都责怪Sofia，尽管Sofia对此一无所知。没去那是Robert自己的决定。
At one point, when I was getting near the end of my rope, I talked to his family about making him stay after school in the classroom just so he can get his homework done. And I think we did it for like a week or two. And I don't think it was very successful. It wasn't a habit he could replicate at home.
大多数时候，Sofia觉得自己已经对Robert尽了力。但她不确定。当想到他时她感到难过——难过是因为没能走进他的内心，难过是因为对他太严厉。在接下来的几年里，她害怕在街区见到Robert，尤其是他和她认识的其他孩子在一起时，比如Lilly。然后有一天，Sofia听说Robert死了，被人刺死，原因至今无人知晓。他两周前刚满16岁。
Incidents between Sofia and Robert piled up, and the year ended badly between them. Someone wrote an obscenity about Sofia on the school wall, up high where only a tall kid could write. And our principal was convinced it was Robert. He ended up being banned from the big end-of-the-year party. When Robert didn't show up at graduation, other kids at the school, including Lilly, blamed Sofia, even though Sofia had nothing to do with it. Not going had been Robert's decision.
Robert遇害后，我做了一个噩梦。我梦见，我不知道，班上的两三个女孩对我真的很不满。她们谈到了我曾要求Robert放学留下来写作业的那次。其中一个女孩指责我阻止他参加篮球队。她说因为我不让他那样做，还让他放学留下来做作业，他没机会交到更好的朋友，也没机会做对他来说更好、更富有成效的事情。我真的觉得也许她们说得有道理。
Mostly, Sofia felt she'd done the best that she could with Robert. But she wasn't sure. She felt bad when she thought about him-- bad for not reaching him, bad for having been hard on him. And for the next few years, she dreaded seeing Robert around the neighborhood, especially with other kids she knew, like Lilly. And then one day, Sofia heard Robert was dead, stabbed to death for reasons no one knows even today. He had just turned 16 two weeks before.
如果没发生别的事，Robert会在Sofia的脑海里这样停留多年，一个她一直感到遗憾、一直希望自己能做得更好的孩子。但在Robert去世六周后，Lilly回到了她以前的小学，毫无预兆地出现在Sofia的教室里。她做了一件我们学生从没做过的事。
After Robert was killed, I had this nightmare. I dreamt that, I don't know, two or three of the girls in that class were really upset with me. And they were talking about the time when I had asked Robert to stay after school and work on his homework. One of the girls had accused me of preventing him from joining a basketball league. And she said that because I didn't let him do that and because I made him stay after school to work on his homework, he didn't get a chance to make better friends and do something that was better for him and more productive. And I really felt like maybe they have something there.
我很惊讶能在我的房间里、我的班级里见到她，来拜访我。然后她说，嗯，我想给你这个。她递给我一张她写的纸条。然后她就离开了。
If nothing else had happened, Robert would have stayed like that in Sofia's head for years, a kid she always had regrets about, always wished she'd done a better job with. But about six weeks after Robert died, Lilly came back to her old elementary school and showed up in Sofia's classroom out of the blue. And she did something none of our students had ever done.
当我读到纸条时，我简直不敢相信——我简直不敢相信。我不得不把那封信重读了一遍。我把它放在钱包里。我想把它装裱起来，但有时我觉得我只是需要重读那封信，只是为了提醒自己。
I was surprised to see her, of all people, in my room, in my class, visiting me. And then she said, well, I wanted to give you this. And she handed me a note that she'd written. And then she left.
你介意现在把它拿出来吗？
And then when I read the note, I couldn't believe-- I just couldn't believe it. I had to read the letter over again. I keep it in my wallet. I wanted to frame it, but sometimes I feel like I just need to read that letter again, just to remind me.
当然，我读一下。
Would you mind getting it now?
（纸张展开的声音）
Sure, I'll read it.
亲爱的Sofia，这是一封我和Rob写给你的感谢信。非常感谢你来参加Rob的葬礼。我知道看到这么多人出现对Rob来说意味着很多。在过去三年里——好吧，四年——自从我和Rob离开邻里学校以来，我们一直是最好的朋友，每天都在一起。
[PAPER UNFOLDING]
我只是想让你知道Rob有多感激你作为一个老师为他所做的一切。每当我们谈论过去时，他说他理解你为他做的一切，而且他很感激。他让我看到人们在乎你。那就是为什么有时他们很严厉。因为这个原因，我谢谢你教会了他这一点。Rob总是喜欢当人们向他展示他们关心他时。他非常关心你。希望很快能见到你。Lilly Torres。
Dear Sofia, This is a letter of appreciation to you from me and Rob. Thank you very much for coming to Rob's wake. I know it would have meant so much to him to see how many people showed up. In the past three years-- well, four years-- since me and Rob left the Neighborhood School, we have been best friends, together every day.
Lilly在悲伤时冲动地给Sofia写了那张纸条。她不确定这样做是对的，或者是不是很奇怪，甚至Rob会怎么想。但在她劝说自己放弃之前，她坐在厨房柜台边，把它写在一张粉色的便利贴上。
I just wanted to let you know how much Rob appreciated what you did for him as a teacher. Whenever we would talk about the past, he said that he understood everything you did for him and that he was grateful for it. He showed me that people care for you. That's why sometimes they are harsh. For that reason, I thank you for teaching it to him. Rob always liked when people showed him they cared. He cared for you very much. Hope to see you soon. Lilly Torres.
我认为关键是，我真的很想让人们知道他是一个非常好的人。我是说，你知道，老师总是对他没好感。我只是可能心想，是的，也许甚至只有一位他曾有过的老师知道他喜欢他们，或者——你知道，不是要改变他在他曾拥有的每一位老师眼中的名声。但我只是想帮他洗清一点那样的名声，因为我不认为他真的应该得到任何负面评价。
Lilly wrote the note to Sofia on an impulse while she was grieving. She wasn't sure if it was the right thing to do, or if it was weird, or even if Robert would approve. But before she could talk herself out of it, she sat down at her kitchen counter and wrote it on a pink Post-it.
关于她，他非常成熟。但我完全不是。我想——我心想也许通过向她展示那个，她会知道他其实最终成长得很好。他说，“我不生气，因为我认为她在尝试为我做最好的事。”因为我们当时正在谈论Sofia。我只是那种，“她不知道怎么应付你。”
I think the thing is, I really wanted people to know that he was a really great person. I mean, you know, teachers were just always not liking him. And I just maybe thought, yeah, maybe even if one teacher that he had knew that he liked them or that-- you know, not to change his reputation with every teacher that he ever had. But I was just trying to take a little bit of that off of his name because I don't think he really deserved any bad at all.
然后他就像，“你在说什么，她不知道怎么应付我？我很坏。而她只是试图帮助我。”他说他很感谢她花时间去关心他，即使是吼叫或者无论那是什么。他说这向他展示了她是关心的。
He was so mature about that whole thing about her. And I wasn't at all. And I wanted-- I thought maybe by showing her that that she would know that he actually turned out pretty well. He said, "I'm not mad because I think that she was trying to do the best thing that she could for me." Because we were talking about Sofia. I was just kind of like, "she didn't know how to handle you."
Sofia从没回信给Lilly。她曾想找到最完美的方式来感谢她，但她拿不定主意该说什么。然后她想时间过去太久了。虽然Lilly不那么认为。
And he was like, "what are you talking about, she didn't know how to handle me? I was bad. And she was just trying to help me." And he said that he was thankful that she took the time out to even care about him, even if it was yelling or whatever it was. He said that it showed him that she cared.
如果她不回信或者她回了，都没关系。我不认为有什么“太晚了”一说。你永远不知道人们需要知道什么。
Sofia never wrote back to Lilly. She'd wanted to find the perfect way to thank her, but she couldn't decide what to say. And then she figured too much time had passed. Though Lilly doesn't see it that way.
在我和她交谈之前，Lilly不知道那张纸条对Sofia意义有多大，Sofia把纸条放在钱包里，它消除了她多年的内疚。对Lilly来说，这张纸条是为了拯救Robert，他留在世上的那部分。她没意识到它也会拯救Sofia。
It's fine if she doesn't write me back or if she does. I don't think it's ever too late. You just never know what people need to know.
Eve Abrams。那实际上是我们八年前第一次播出的故事。Sofia现在仍然在那所学校教书。Lilly，那个16岁的女孩，现在拥有音乐商业硕士学位，在Electric Lady Studios工作。
Until I spoke to her, Lilly had no idea how much her note had meant to Sofia, that Sofia kept the note in her wallet, that it had lifted away years of guilt. For Lilly, the note was about saving Robert, the part of him that was left in the world. She hadn't realized that it would also rescue Sofia.
第四幕。好的，所以我们今天的主题是“我以为我认识你”。我们节目今天的第四幕标题是“我以为我认识U2”。有个关于U2的播客，U2乐队，是由《公园与游憩》的Adam Scott和《Comedy Bang Bang!》的Scott Aukerman做的。而且，你知道，他们真的很迷U2，正如你对制作U2播客的人所期望的那样。所以他们坐下来谈论乐队，分析他们的专辑，诸如此类。
Eve Abrams. That's actually a story that we first broadcast eight years ago. Sofia is still a teacher at the same school. Lilly, the 16-year-old, now has a master's in music business and works at Electric Lady Studios.
他们不久前做了件事，在这个狂热的U2粉丝窝里，他们带进了一个对U2一无所知的人，一位叫Todd Glass的喜剧演员，他也有自己的播客。顺便说一句，他和我没关系。而发生的事情就是一场非常有趣的物质-反物质碰撞。Todd Glass解释说他真的对音乐、对任何乐队都不了解。我们从那儿开始吧。
Act Four. OK, so our theme today is I Thought I Knew You. And Act Four of our show today is titled I Thought I Knew U2. There's this podcast about U2, the band U2, that's done by Adam Scott from Parks and Rec and Scott Aukerman, who you may know from Comedy Bang Bang! And, you know, they're really into U2, as you would expect from people who are making a podcast about U2. So they sit and they talk about the band, and they break down their albums, that kind of thing.
U2我知道——这是进入我不知道的部分。主唱得到了——U2的，他叫什么名字？
And they did this thing not long ago where into this den of intense U2 fandom, they brought somebody who knows nothing about U2, a comedian named Todd Glass, who also has his own podcast. No relation to me, by the way. And what happens is just this very fun to listen to matter-antimatter collision. Todd Glass explains that he doesn't know really much about music, about any band. And let's just pick it up from there.
我们不会告诉你的。
U2 I know-- here's when it comes into the part I don't know. The lead singer gets-- of U2, what is his name?
他因为把自己看得太重而受到很多调侃。就像，他在世界饥饿——
We're not going to tell you.
是的，是的，是的。
He gets teased a lot for taking himself too seriously. Like, he's in the world hunger--
我们什么都不会告诉你的。我想听到所有你知道关于U2的事。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
嗯，我知道，噢，有太多关于——有一首歌关于，关于，呃——不是有一首歌他为某个大型活动做的，为了筹钱——就像它真的很——我肯定有很多歌。但这首歌是为一件特别的事写的。没有吗？
We're not going to tell you anything. I want to hear everything you know about U2.
没有。我不知道。我只是好奇你知道什么。
Well, I know that, oh, there's so much right on the-- there's a song about, about, uh-- isn't there a song that he did for some big, like, event to raise money for some-- like it was like really-- I'm sure there's a lot of songs. But this was written for one thing particular. No?
该死，你不能告诉我他的名字吗？我在想象他戴着大眼镜。他的头发顶部有点稀疏。
No. I don't know. I'm just wondering what you know.
关于U2还有什么？
Goddammit, can't you give me his first name? I'm picturing him with his big glasses. And he has his hair sort of thinning up top.
关于U2你还知道什么？生活经历？任何事。
What else about U2?
我只知道他戴着那些——
What else do you know about U2? Life experiences? Anything.
任何你接触过的——
I just know he wears those--
歌曲？
Any contact you--
大眼镜。不，我不——如果你告诉我一首歌，我会真诚地，就像，它从你嘴里说出来时。那种事情。我会说，噢，是的！
Songs?
所以这就是你知道的。你甚至不能告诉我们一首歌的名字。
Big glasses. No, I don't-- if you told me a song, I would genuinely, like, as it's coming out your mouth. One of those things. I'd be like, oh, yeah!
不能。但如果你播放歌曲——
So that's what you know. You could not even tell us one name of one song.
我可以播放一点吗？
No. But if you played songs--
如果你播放一点我会知道。但说真的，别告诉我它是不是。别直接放他的歌。我敢打赌，我心跳间就能告诉你那是他的歌还是不。
Can I play something?
好的。那我放一首歌。
I would know if you played something. But seriously, don't tell me if it's going to be it or not. Don't just play his song. I'll tell you if it's his song or not in a heartbeat, I bet.
而且我会知道它是他的歌还是不，心跳间，我想象。也许我错了。
OK. So I'll play a song.
好的。那我放一首歌。你告诉我这是Bono唱的U2歌曲吗。
And I'll know if it's his song or not, in a heartbeat, I would imagine. Maybe I'm wrong.
好的。而且我会——只是让你知道，我想我能很快知道。
OK. So I'm going to play a song. You tell me if this is a U2 song sung by Bono.
（音乐 - Gerry Rafferty的“Baker Street”）
OK. And I'm gonna-- just so you know, I think I could know pretty quick.
不是。它没有足够的灵魂。
[MUSIC - "BAKER STREET" BY GERRY RAFFERTY]
好的。
No. It doesn't have enough soul.
我这么说对吗？
OK.
你对了。那是Gerry Rafferty的“Baker Street”。
Would I be right to say that?
是的。
You are. That was Gerry Rafferty, "Baker Street."
好吧。
Yeah.
嗯，下一首可能是他的。
All right.
好吧。开始了。准备好了吗？
Well, the next one is gonna be him probably.
（音乐 - Steely Dan的“Hey Nineteen”）
All right. Here we go. Ready?
不。不。
[MUSIC - "HEY NINETEEN" BY STEELY DAN]
你对了。这是Steely Dan的“Hey Nineteen”。好吧。其中一首会是U2。
No. No.
好的。
You're right. This is Steely Dan, "Hey Nineteen." All right. One of these is gonna be U2.
好了。准备好了吗？
OK.
嗯哼。
All right. You ready?
（音乐 - Weezer的“Buddy Holly”）
Uh-huh.
我猜不是。
[MUSIC - "BUDDY HOLLY" BY WEEZER]
你对了。那是Weezer的“Buddy Holly”。
I'm gonna say no.
这是我生命中最伟大的时刻之一，就听着这个。
You are right. That is Weezer, "Buddy Holly."
好了。准备好了吗？
This is one of the greatest moments of my life, just listening to this.
好的。
All right. Ready?
好了。开始了。
OK.
到这一点，肯定就是它了。
All right. Here we go.
（音乐 - Peter Gabriel的“Sledgehammer”）
At this point, it's got to be it.
是的。不。等等。等一下，等一下，等一下！好的。
[MUSIC - "SLEDGEHAMMER" BY PETER GABRIEL]
别——让我回答。我老了，但是是的。这是他较早的作品，但是的。
Yes. No. Wait. Hold on, hold on, hold on! OK.
错误。这是Peter Gabriel的“Sledgehammer”。
Don't-- let me answer. This is I'm older, but yes. It's an older work of his, but yes.
啊，（消音）。我知道它不是，但发生的事是——我的直觉告诉我它不是。但我心想，好吧，他会放多少首才到它？所以我说，别相信你的直觉。
Incorrect. This is Peter Gabriel, "Sledgehammer."
我可以放一首歌给你听吗？
Ah, [BLEEP]. I knew it wasn't it, but here's what happened-- my instincts where that it wasn't it. But I thought, well, how many will he play before it's it? So I said, don't trust your instincts.
嗯，是的。最后，在这一点上，我想这对我会更好。
Can I just play you a song?
好的。我正试图想想你会知道什么歌。
Well, yeah. Finally, at this point, I think it would be better for me.
我会看向别处。你决定。
All right. I'm trying to think of what song you would know.
好了。好的。好的。这是——好的。我想这是你会知道的歌。等等。
I'm going to look away. You decide.
（音乐 - Gary Portnoy的“Where Everybody Knows Your Name”）
All right. OK. OK. Here's-- all right. This is-- OK. I think this is the song that you would know. Hold on.
不，这不是他。不。
[MUSIC - "WHERE EVERYBODY KNOWS YOUR NAME" BY GARY PORTNOY]
这是他。
No, this isn't him. No.
不是。噢。
This is him.
（笑声）
No it isn't. Oh.
我很确定这是他。
[LAUGHTER]
这绝对是他。
I'm pretty sure this is him.
这不是他？
This is definitely him.
好吧，看。
This isn't him?
好的。
All right, look.
Scott。
All right.
是的。
Scott.
别废话（消音）。播放那首歌。看着我的眼睛，播放一首真正的歌。别在这里（消音）瞎搞了。
Yes.
好的。我得找到它。
No bull [BLEEP]. Play the song. Look me in the eye, and play a real song. And stop [BLEEP] around here.
我能认出来。
All right. I got to find it.
我得找到它。
I'll be able to tell.
就播放那首歌。说真的。
I got to find it.
好的。呃——
Just play the song. Seriously.
Scott，看着我的眼睛！
OK. Uh--
我看着你的眼睛，是的。
Scott, look me in the eye!
好的。
I am looking you in the eye, yes.
OK.
让我听听YouTube——一首U2歌曲。
好的。开始了。这是U2。
Let me just hear a YouTube-- a U2 song.
我会认出来的。
All right. Here we go. This is U2.
这可能是U2最著名的歌，我会说，在所有歌中。
I'll recognize it.
是的。别放新的。播放——
This is probably U2's most famous song, I would say, out of all of them.
（音乐 - Fats Domino的“Blueberry Hill”）
Yeah. Don't play something new. Play--
我知道这就是他们。好的。现在真的播放他们的歌。
[MUSIC - "BLUEBERRY HILL" BY FATS DOMINO]
好的。这是真正的——
I knew this was them. OK. Now really play their song.
现在我真的想听听它。
OK. Here's the real--
噢，它连上了。好了。
Now I really do want to hear it.
（音乐播放）
Oh, it's connecting. All right.
好的。这是一首新歌。这是U2吗？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
（音乐 - U2的“I Still Haven't Found What I'm Looking For”）
All right. Here's a new song. Is this U2?
是的。我知道这首歌。耶稣基督，你知道我有多累吗？
[MUSIC - "I STILL HAVEN'T FOUND WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR" BY U2]
是的，我能想象。
Yes. I know this song. Jesus Christ, you know how exhausted I am?
噢，那很有趣。
Yeah, I would imagine.
我真的喘不过气了。
Oh, that was fun.
我本来可以永远那么做的，虽然。就听着——
I'm literally out of breath.
我喜欢它。
I could have done that forever, though. Just listened to--
（音乐 - U2的“I Still Haven't Found What I'm Looking For”）
I loved it.
Adam Scott, Scott Aukerman, 以及来自播客《You Talkin' U2 to Me?》的Todd Glass。完整剧集请在earwolf.com收听。
[MUSIC - "I STILL HAVEN'T FOUND WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR" BY U2]
我们的节目今天由Jonathan Menjivar和我自己制作，Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan以及Nancy Updike参与。我们的资深制作人是Brian Reed。我们的编辑是Joel Lovell。Julie Snyder是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。Christopher Swetala提供研究帮助。Lyra Smith提供制作帮助。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的业务运营经理。Elna Baker为节目寻找故事。Kimberly Henderson是我们的办公室协调员。Damien Gray和Rob Geddis提供今日音乐帮助。
Adam Scott, Scott Aukerman, and Todd Glass from the podcast You Talkin' U2 to Me? Full episodes at earwolf.com.
（致谢）
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar and myself with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Research help from Christopher Swetala. Production help from Lyra Smith. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for the show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Music help today from Damien Gray and from Rob Geddis.
在节目开头讲述房地产经纪人故事的Adam Mansbach是多本书的作者，包括《给我滚去睡觉》。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易中心送达公共广播电台。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他当时在帮我搬家，顺手拿走了我的一本旧相册。留了好几个月。终于，就在这周，他还给了我并向我道歉。
Adam Mansbach, who told the story about the real estate agent at the beginning of the program, is the author of several books, including Go the [BLEEP] to Sleep. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
“哟，伙计，你的专辑对我意义重大。”
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He was helping me move and swiped one of my old photo albums. Kept it months. Finally, just this week, he gave it back to me and apologized.
我是Ira Glass。下周带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
Yo man, your album was really significant to me.
（音乐 - U2的“I Still Haven't Found What I'm Looking For”）
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是伊拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，继续为您带来《美国生活》的更多故事。
[MUSIC - "I STILL HAVEN'T FOUND WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR" BY U2]
[音乐 - U2乐队的《我依然没找到我所寻找的》]